I mean he probably you'll never know the
effect that uh that short time you know
in West Texas had on me
do you remember the first time you met
Matt Damon oh wow uh the first time I
met him yeah so I did a movie uh I was
18 years old it was the first movie that
I the first job that I'd been able to do
without my mom traveling with me right
so uh I went by myself to West Texas to
Alpine Texas which is a small town now
but in 1994 was a much smaller smaller
town apparently and I was staying in a
Motel 6 and uh I met the guy who was
gonna play my older brother who was Matt
Damon who I didn't know from anything
you know like I
um he wasn't famous to me he was just a
guy and he was very kind to me and um
like he was 26 I think 25 26 but you
know what it's like when you're 26 and
you have to hang out with this 18 year
old you know um but he did he was very
cool and the the other the movie is
called the good old boys and it was
directed by Tom Lee Jones and it started
France McDormand and Terry Kinney and
Sam Shepard and Wilford Brimley and like
all of these big huge names and um Matt
was kind enough to kind of let me tag
along with him through his conversations
with these people because I was a new
fight at the very least but I remember
one of the things that really stands out
to me as we were at dinner with Sam
Shepard and I knew Sam Shepard from the
right stuff or you know uh the Pelican
Brief really is more accurate from what
I knew him from at the time but uh Matt
was like wow so I saw your new show on
Broadway and it just amazing and I was
like oh you write plays and man it was
like just shut up and you might learn
something okay these are amazing people
that were around
um so he was great and he actually was
kind of the inspiration for me starting
to write because
um he and Ben were working on Goodwill
Hunting at the time and they were faxing
back and forth note to each other that's
how long ago was and I expressed
interest and it's like well you can read
it if you want I'm like yeah I would
love that and I read an early draft of
the script and I'm like you're going to
write this for you to star in and he's
like yeah I'm like that's a million
dollar idea because that's what I want
to do I want to be a movie star and blah
blah blah so
um I got back to LA and I kind of did
the same thing I I wrote a movie with my
roommate and somehow that movie ended up
getting financed and made and I had to
take a smaller part but um you know to
just Gordon-Levitt who played the lead
as a movie called manic but that only
happened because I had worked with Matt
and I saw him writing and trying to
expand his skill set and do other things
other than just wait for the phone to
ring and I found that really inspiring
how many days were you on set
uh for that first one for good old boys
um well it was I mean it was just a
great great job it was one of those
things where it's like I I feel like
Matt has talked later about how he it
was the lowest point of his young career
because he was he had been up for a lot
of giant things and Leo DiCaprio kept
beating him out on you know it was like
he was in this point where he was like
at the lowest right before he was able
to break through with you know mostly
some of his own work but also Rainmaker
and stuff like that
um but for me it was a pinnacle right so
it's so funny for me to be in this
situation where all the actors except
for Francis McDormand and Tommy Lee
Jones were basically in a Motel 6 and
they were all kind of like you know
begrudgingly there for Tommy Lee Jones
because you know he's great and people
will do a lot of things to be in a Tommy
Lee Jones movie uh but for me I was like
I felt like I won the lottery you know
um so I was there the whole time which
was very cool
um it was like I said it was in West
Texas and it was all uh horses and
cowboy stuff so I got to go out two
weeks early and ride horses and work on
roping and like do all this stuff that
is just kind of a dream scenario it was
like Camp you know and then afterwards I
would get to hang out and listen to
Amazing Stories you know from Sam
Shepard or Matt Damon or Francis
McDormand who's amazing and was so kind
to me that uh I just I I kind of look
back on it I'm like wow what a so
surreal and what a great you know break
into the business really because I've
done a TV movie before then but this was
absolutely the biggest thing and it
meant when I left there and moved to Los
Angeles that I would have an agent that
I would be in the union that I would you
know all these things that I didn't even
know to worry about or taken care of
because of this great job
um yeah but I was there probably
probably eight weeks all told
do you remember what scene he showed you
from the the did you touch the fax paper
or no this was like oh no I read the
whole thing it gave me the whole thing
uh and it used to be a spy movie and
it's kind of crazy but I I always talk
about it when I'm talking about
screenwriting about how
things change how the the process is so
organic right uh but the original
version of Goodwill Hunting that I read
at least was kind of a spy movie
um about and there's a scene in Goodwill
Hunting where
um will is interviewing with the CIA and
they're like why are you reluctant to
sign with us and he was like why because
what if I crack a code and this happens
and this place gets bombed and
that whole Spiel that was the plot of
the movie the original movie and the
story that Matt
has told I don't think he told me this I
think he said this on TV or something
but I was very interested about how that
became the Goodwill Hunting that we know
and he said that Rob Reiner uh read the
script and was like this is good I like
all of it but what you should do is
focus on the friendship and they were
like well we already sold this movie
though and he's like yeah nobody cares
anymore though they own it and they want
to make it so make it something that
they're excited to make
I mean that's not really my story that's
match but uh yeah the the version that I
read was absolutely a spy movie and then
I saw the uh trailer and I'm like well
this is this has gone through some
changes
and that taught you about the business
too I obviously I'm sure or maybe you
didn't realize it at the time but there
will be so many iterations of something
absolutely and like things change on a
dime and like that is something that
keeps I keep learning I keep relearning
this fact of like you know
um you write a script with a certain
person in mind and then that person
can't do it so then you have another
person who's also a very talented person
but very different than that person are
okay script is now different the story
is now different right uh there's no
version where you know these two or
three or five actors that you've thought
about are gonna do it the same right you
have to acknowledge who they are as well
as what the script says in order to you
know make it happen I mean we did uh six
month rules ages ago you know and um it
was originally we were speaking to
Rachel Lee Cook about the lead role and
uh she's around my age you know and it
was like that was kind of what the
script was and then that didn't work out
and we went and we I just done a TV show
with Natalie Morales uh who's amazing
and great and I was like we'd be lucky
to get her and so we made this offer and
we got her and then I realized
throughout the next couple of days
because you know you get really frantic
about casting right it's like we have to
do it we have to we you know we don't
want to do too much research anyways I
find out that she's much younger than me
you know she's at least 10 years younger
than me and I was like oh well that kind
of changes so many things in the movie
and so we had to acknowledge it we can't
just pretend that that's not a thing
right and so suddenly you know Natalie
becomes this role of Sophie and then we
have to figure out what the movie is now
right we can't just keep going on the
same path that we were on you know does
that make sense it yep
but it's always changing it's always uh
has to stay organic and Alive because
the moment that you start saying No this
is what I decided to do in my bedroom
when I was writing it you know or when I
was meeting with the DP this is what we
decided that's when the movie stops
being alive and starts being a little
stale I think when you looked at the
script for Goodwill Hunting which at
that time was a spy film right right
what feedback did you provide Matt Damon
oh I wasn't I wasn't anywhere near a
point where I could do something like
that I you know I I think about
um
my youth and uh coming up and you know I
deal with a lot of young actors now uh I
do some teaching at a university and so
I I interact with 18 19 20 year olds all
the time and I'm constantly like I can't
believe I was working you know on my own
without any parental you know guidance
or whatever at that age I was so dumb I
was so dumb and it's like you just don't
know what you don't know right and um I
certainly wouldn't have ever thought to
give a note or anything I mean he asked
for them and I'm like I don't know like
this is great like this is the first
movie script I've ever read that was
written by somebody I know
if you think about it that way I grew up
doing theater
um I would audition for TV and movies
all the time but like the writer was
something that I never thought I could
be because it was so special and you
know you had to be a genius to do
something like that so when I read that
first script it was the first thing that
made it a attainable and something that
wasn't
The Wizard of Oz kind of stuff pay no
attention to the man behind the curtain
uh it was the first chance I saw him
like Matt's a regular guy you know he's
a smart guy he's an articular guy
um but I also don't feel like he's some
genius that you know dropped out from
heaven and you know he's just a guy and
that made it kind of attainable for me
of like wanting to re to write more and
and chasing that dream
um but yeah I didn't offer him any notes
I was just like awesome this is great
really good can I audition for it you
know
how long after that did you see him have
success with the film uh well I I got a
good story about that actually because
uh I ended up um I was going to acting
school uh right before I did the the
Western and I did the Western and then I
was surrounded by Again Sam Shepard Matt
Damon you know what since he's basic
Tommy Lee Jones who went to Harvard all
these people who knew all about all
kinds of stuff like not just acting they
knew like everything they were having
these intellectual discussions at dinner
that I was totally lost by and I was
like all right I don't want to just
study acting I'm gonna study everything
I'm gonna you know you know Matt was
going to Harvard you know and I'm like I
want to do that I want to be one of the
smart people at the table so
um I I left New York which is where the
acting school was and I came to LA and I
uh signed up for Santa Monica College
and I did a couple years there and I
ended up transferring to UCLA and I got
a degree in English and political
science and like something completely
different than acting because I wanted
to expand uh my life you know I wanted
to know about more stuff than just
stanislavski and my Meisner and you know
all that jazz which is very important
and I love but I just wanted to have a
deeper well to pull from but I'm at UCLA
I'm uh you know uh there in Westwood
Village and me and my roommate had gone
up there to run some errands and play
some video games so I had a bag of Tide
uh that I had just purchased and we saw
that the uh premiere of Goodwill Hunting
was happening and they were you know
about to let out and I turned to my
buddy Mike I'm like I know that guy I
know Matt like we're friends you know we
did this movie together like two or
three years ago
um and he's like whoa we should hang out
and so they the movie let out and we're
like behind the security guys and
looking around and Robin Williams walks
by and I'm like wow so cool and uh then
I kind of took one too many steps
towards the door and the security guy
kind of pushed me back and I'm like uh I
hate that I'm like I'm embarrassed now
let's just leave and my buddy's like no
no no we should stay so we stayed a few
more minutes and then Matt came out and
I was behind probably seven people you
know stacked pretty deep and I did one
of these things
and he caught my eye and he was on top
of the world and he was like hey little
brother and he pulled me in and he's
like you know gave me a hug he's like
are you going to this party I'm like no
man I'm just I literally was just he's
like you're going to this party
so he puts he drags me into the
limousine with himself and his mom and
Minnie Driver and they're just all like
you know talking about how great the
movie is they had not seen the movie yet
and they were you know very excited
about it and I'm sitting there I've got
a bag of Tide under my feet so the whole
limousine smells like you know Tide
detergent and uh I've got like ripped
jeans on and I'm like don't know what to
say I'm just like the trailer looks
really good man yeah I bet it's good I
bet it's good anyway if we drove around
the corner to this very very fancy uh
wrap party that the studio had thrown
for them and I I didn't want to be a
hanger on I didn't want to like infringe
on him anymore than I had I would but so
I was just like I'm not going in just
thank you for inviting me like that's so
cool such a great guy so unnecessary you
know uh and I just went back and I
played video games at night and my
buddy's like why didn't you go like I
feel like the story is that he wanted me
to go you know what I mean as opposed to
me wandering around not knowing anybody
at a premier party and with my bag of
Tide
um but it was great it was a a great
moment for me but uh yeah and since then
I've been one you know Super Fan I I
love everything that he does I think
he's incredibly talented and smart
and also you saw that writing your own
project and yeah trying to get it made I
mean he probably you'll never know the
effect that uh that short time you know
uh in West Texas had on me
um but I think that's you know when you
in this business
it's always these short amount of times
in West Texas or LA or location wherever
right and you can really uh I I've
learned that the effect that you can
have on other people is uh dramatic
dramatic because a lot of people don't
get to make movies uh it's pretty rare
for most people to be on a movie set and
just because it's our kind of bread and
butter and we do it a lot uh it doesn't
mean that that's how it is for the
entire cast and crew and I always think
about the effect that those people had
on me you know they made me want to be
smarter they made me want to be more
educated uh they made me want to take my
craft more seriously and this is all
just because we would get together for
dinner and they were kind to me and they
would sit and talk and I would listen
and I would be like wow that's who I
want to be you know I thought I wanted
to be you know whatever the movie star
was and you know 1992 five or whatever
and but instead I'm like I want to be
the person who goes from uh Broadway
stage to you know deep Indie drama to
cowboy movie to you know which is the
kind of stuff that Francis mcdorm was
doing like you know right after that
right after that Fargo came out and
she'd already done it and I was like
this is amazing you have already done an
Oscar winning performance and then you
came in you did this small low budget
you know Western
um and then you go and accept your award
for Fargo in it but
they're all kind of Heroes to me